Chuck. Come here.
Get in here close,
close, close, close, close.
Too close.
Back up a little bit.
Good. Good.
Are the liberals gone?
(laughter)
Quick test.
When they go low...
-Perfect. We're alone.
-(laughter)
It's time for Just Between Us.
-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)
Just between us, gun rights
are stronger than ever.
In fact, that same panel
that's advocating
stronger background checks
is also about to pass
a breakthrough pro-gun measure
this week. Look at this.
In a major victory
for gun rights advocates,
a House committee advanced
the Republican
Concealed Carry
Reciprocity Act.
Backed by the NRA, it would
allow gun owners to carry
their concealed weapons across
state lines with a permit.
Our rights should not end
where a state line ends.
This is about the equal access
of your pro-choice right
of self-defense.
(quietly):
Yeah, suck it, snowflakes.
(laughter)
Pro-choice is our thing now.
Next we're coming
for their electric cars.
We're gonna make them run
on elephant blood.
Let's break this down.
What is gun reciprocity?
First off, don't worry.
I know "reciprocity" sounds
like some YA novel
about high schoolers
with awesome powers...
And that's because it is--
I wrote it.
But... the reciprocity
I'm talking about is way cooler.
Gun reciprocity means that
if you're allowed to carry a gun
in your state, you're allowed
to do it in any other state.
And 12 states
don't have any restrictions
beyond the minimum
federal requirements.
Live in those states,
it's awesome.
Any day could turn
into a Die Hard movie.
(laughter)
Wyoming is, like,
85% Bruce Willisese.
(laughter)
This new bill is beautiful,
because it lowers the bar
across the country,
so that every state has to abide
by the loosest
concealed-carry laws.
Americans love lowering the bar.
It's so much easier
to get over it that way.
Now, to get specific,
let's look at the laws
of a state like Georgia.
Say you're a convicted
domestic abuser who lives there.
You have
a conceal-and-carry permit,
because Georgia allows you to,
despite your abuse conviction.
Then you come to a liberal
hellhole like New York
that doesn't allow
domestic abusers to carry guns.
I know. Crazy.
Under the reciprocity bill,
you'd still be allowed
to carry that gun.
All right,
I know what you're thinking:
Jordan, a domestic abuser
is not a good guy with a gun.
Yes. Well, of course.
In Georgia he's not.
But in New York,
maybe he would be.
(laughter)
It's like Sinatra said,
"If you can make it here...
with a gun,
you can make it anywhere...
with a gun."
Reciprocity is like
if all the gunslingers
in HBO's Westworld
started showing up in other
shows with their guns.
America just put more "bang"
in The Big Bang Theory.
And just between us,
it gets even better,
because America is still
gunny as (bleep).
And it's not just the adults.
TV REPORTER: Wisconsin's new law
that allows hunters
of any age to carry a weapon
has already led to licenses
being sold to infants.
Ten mentored hunting licenses
were sold over
the last two weeks,
all to children
under the age of one.
(audience exclaims)
The terrible twos just got real.
(cheers and applause)
It's... it is great that this
passed in Wisconsin,
but you know
what's even greater?
Wisconsin became the 35th state
with no minimum hunting age.
They may not be able to stand
their ground yet,
but they can definitely do
"tummy time" on their ground.
Gun advocates are gun-racking up
wins all over,
no matter what the libs
are celebrating.
I mean,
just look at our president:
you really think this guy will
allow meaningful gun control?
I have a license to carry
in New York.
Can you believe that?
Nobody knows that.
(mimics gunshot)
(mimics gunshots)
Yeah. Oh.
(mimics gunshot)
You can tell Trump's a pro.
Rule number one: whenever you
shoot, look dope as hell.
Now, remember, this whole thing
is just between us.
Don't let any of those
pomegranate-juicing liberals
hear about reciprocity.
And especially, don't let them
call this one number,
which will connect them
to their representative,
so they can weigh-in on the
National Carry Reciprocity Act.
-Shh, shh. Shh.
-(cheers and applause)
It's happening this week.
Shh, shh.
Oh, yeah, and definitely do not
take a picture of this,
and definitely do not post it
on social media.
Yeah. If they get their hands,
on this,
these liberals are going to grab
onto these dangerous opinions,
conceal and carry them,
and then whip them out
when we least expect it.